In terms of the
session objectives,
you'll see that when we're
looking at all of the
slides and the material
that's being presented,
much of the content has
stayed the same and many
of the disease processes
that are mentioned have
also stayed the same
over the years, but the
objectives are also going
to be somewhat different
compared to what we've
seen in the years past,
partially because I want
you to be able to leave
this lecture and compare
and contrast some
of the tests that are
being able to be ordered
and performed for each
disease process, and
also what the clinical
presentations look like.
So in going through the
objectives for today, we'll
talk about the mechanisms
by which each disease
process occurs, we'll talk
about the different clinical
and lab findings as well
as the signs and symptoms
for each disease, and
there's also many diseases
where we'll talk about just
organ specific findings,
limitations to one organ
versus systemic disease.
Furthermore, we'll talk
about diagnostic tests
which will kind of
differentiate one disease
process from another
with some overlap. This
is a very common thing
that you'll be tested
on and a very common
thing that you'll need to
know for when you're
in your clinical years.
Furthermore, we'll be
talking briefly about
the treatment for each
discussed disease process
and pathology and also
looking at comparisons
and contrasting different
lab findings and
clinical findings throughout
the board as well.
so here we have a brief
session outline but overall
what we'll be covering is
autoimmune diseases which
kind of have a central focus
in the mechanisms of what
they're going to be
presenting with so we have our
own actual immune system and
not going into the details
of innate versus adaptive
immunity anytime our body
in general comes across
an antigen that it doesn't
recognize or doesn't know,
we are activating our immune
system to try to attack
it. And so what happens in
this case is we have an
immune response to our self
-antigens, and that's what
leads to this autoimmunity.
There is a self-tolerance
mechanism where we're able
to recognize our own
antigens. However, in these
autoimmune processes, this
fails, and this leads to
autoimmune antibodies and
also autoreactive T cells and
overall just an inappropriate
immune response. And so
what we'll be covering is
diseases that not only affect
just the skin, like Sjogren's
syndrome and Pumphagus
vulgaris, but anywhere
along the way of the GI
tract, such as the IBD symptoms
and syndromes, and also
the thyroid glands, to
disease processes that you'll
see day-to-day, such as
insulin-dependent diabetes.
We'll be starting our
discussion with autoimmune
diseases of the endocrine
and exocrine glands. One way
that I like to break down
in my head the distinction
between endocrine versus
exocrine glands, and this may
help in understanding some
of the diseases we'll be
talking about today, is
consider endocrine to be when
our body produces something
like a hormone and it's
secreted systemically throughout
your body whether you're
using arterial or venous
systems. However, when
you're looking at exocrine
glands, think of products
being produced by your body
in one specific organ or
one specific area to be
presented on the surface of
another. The easiest examples
are salivary glands producing
saliva or lacrimal glands
presenting with tears.
Our first disease we'll be
talking about is Hashimoto's
thyroiditis, which is
actually the most common
cause of hypothyroidism in
areas that are not resource
scarce or limited in
iodine. So you'll see this
commonly presented in the
setting of hypothyroidism. In
this case, the concern is
that there are antibodies
to thyroid peroxidase enzyme,
which you'll see centrally
located in this picture.
And what happens is this
enzyme in the thyroid is
actually there to oxidize
the iodide ions which
catalyze the formation of your
T4 and T3 hormones and so
when you have these antibodies
you'll see downstream
effects of not having enough
T3 and T4 ultimately
causing your hypothyroidism.
For Hashimoto's thyroiditis
the mechanism of action
is actually IgG mediated
autoantibody production
against thyroid peroxidase,
which is the enzyme
we mentioned on the
previous screen, as well as
thyroglobulin. And this
is organ-specific, meaning
we're specifically dealing
with infiltration of the
thyroid gland. However,
the signs and symptoms
that you see are going
to be systemic throughout
the body. This is a type 2
hypersensitivity reaction
because we have specific
antibodies targeting
endogenous cells resulting
in ultimate destruction.
In terms of signs and
symptoms and some of the risk
factors, there are environmental
risk factors such as
smoking and drugs as well
as genetic causes such as
HLA or human leukocyte
antigen DR5 and DR3. And what
you'll see on presentation is
someone will have a diffuse
and non-tender large
thyroid or thyroid a megaly.
Furthermore, you'll see
signs and symptoms of
hypothyroidism. People
will complain about
constipation, weight gain,
frail hair, and other
signs and stigmata of
hypothyroid disease.
In terms of the diagnosis
of Hashimoto's thyroiditis,
one of the tests that
we can use is anti
-TPO antibodies against the
thyroid peroxidase enzyme,
and this will actually
be present in about 90
% of cases that we're
dealing with. Furthermore,
you can also test for
antithyroglobulin antibodies
which will be present
in about 40% of cases.
On biopsy, one of the
things that you would find
is follicular damage with
chronic inflammation.
There's also this noted
finding of herthal cells
and really what herthal
cells will distribute and
demonstrate to you are
eosinophilic metaplasia.
In terms of the treatment,
ultimately what this leads
to is hypothyroidism,
and what we'll use for
treatment is levothyroxine,
which is really just a
synthetic version of T3 since
the thyroid is no longer
able to generate this.
One thing that's very
interesting is that originally
in Hashimoto's
thyroiditis, towards the
earlier phases, you can
actually see signs and symptoms
of hyperthyroidism,
meaning too much thyroid
hormone because there's
leaking of the hormones
from follicular damage.
However, ultimately this
will end up leading to
your hypothyroid state.
Now we'll be briefly talking
about insulin-dependent
diabetes mellitus, and in
this case we're talking about
a type 4 hypersensitivity
reaction with involvement
of T cells as well as
macrophagic infiltration into
the beta cells of the
pancreas. So this is organ
-specific, we're dealing with
the pancreatic beta cells
whose role is to produce
insulin, and what we'll see is
not only decreased insulin,
but systemic signs and
symptoms throughout the body
of the sequelae of not having
enough insulin. There are
some genetic predispositions
and associations,
specifically with HLA-DR3 and
DR4, and until this hits a
tipping point, it's often
asymptomatic, but very, very
commonly seen, very commonly
tested in preclinical and
clinical conditions and
situations. You'll have DKA
or diabetic ketoacidosis
as a common initial
presentation. In this case,
patients are often tested
and seen with a high anti-gap
metabolic acidosis and signs
and symptoms of polyuria
and polydipsia, having excessive
thirst and also urinating
quite frequently, and
having not only ketones in
the urine but also glucose.
Your body does its best
to maintain a certain level
of glucose with your kidneys.
However, what happens is
we do urinate out some
of this, and with that comes
osmotic diuresis, glucose,
and water, leading to
overall a dehydrated picture.
In terms of how we test
for insulin-dependent
diabetes mellitus, one
of the most common ways
is with oral blood glucose
testing. So there's
actually parameters set
for what a fasting sugar
or glucose should be
as well as non-fasting.
Furthermore, we also look at
what's called the hemoglobin
A1c above the range of 6
.5. So you'll learn about
pre-diabetic ranges and
diabetic ranges, 6.5 pertaining
to the diabetic range. And
what this test is, is you're
actually looking at your
hemoglobin, which has about
a 90-day lifespan. And with
that, we're looking at the
glycated versions. So
there's actually a part or a
certain amount of your hemoglobin
that has sugar or glucose
molecules attached to it,
calling it glycated, and
the percentage of this is
how you determine your A1c.
It's actually a
three-month average,
and that's actually
referring back to
your RBC, your red
blood cell survival.
There are a few antibodies
that you can see in
this disease process,
specifically the anti-glutamic
acid, as well as the
islet cell cytoplasmic
antibodies. However, these
antibodies don't play
a role in the pathology
like we talked about with
Hashimoto's. They just
seem to be present in
the individuals with
insulin-dependent diabetes.
The treatment mainly
is exogenous insulin
or ultimately a
pancreas transplant.
A lot of times we also
specify type 1 diabetes versus
type 2 diabetes, referring
to type 1 as the autoimmune
variant. However, there's
also a spectrum of diseases
specifically with one called
latent autoimmune disease
of adult or latent autoimmune
diabetes in adults,
in which case you'll also
have a similar pathophysiology
and pathogenesis with an
autoimmune presentation.
Next, we'll be briefly
discussing Sjogren's syndrome,
in which we have a
mechanism of lymphocytic
infiltration as well as
fibrosis leading to destruction,
and in this case it's
primary or secondary,
meaning Sjogren's syndrome
can stand on its own as a
disease process, typically
known as Sikha syndrome,
as mentioned below, or
it's actually a sign and
symptom along with
another form of autoimmune
condition, such as rheumatoid
arthritis, Hashimoto's,
systemic lupus. And this is
another good example, just
like we mentioned with diabetes,
of type 4 hypersensitivity
reaction, because there's
no actual antibody
involvement in the autoimmune
destruction. So in these
patients, what you'll see
is it's not organ-specific,
but it is typically in the
exocrine glands, especially
with the lacrimal and
salivary glands. And so what
you'll see is xerostomia,
which is dry mouth due to
decreased saliva production.
This actually ultimately
leads to mucosal atrophy,
you'll see fissuring of the
tongue, and there's also this
problem of recurrent dental
caries because of the
decreased saliva production.
Furthermore, you also have
keratoconjunctivitis, so
this is dry eyes because
of a decrease in
tear production,
which leads to a higher
risk of corneal damage.
Furthermore, you'll
also see parotid gland
***********, so two of the
salivary glands on either
side of the face, and
the *********** is either
a compensatory mechanism
or because of fatty
tissue replacement,
and ultimately there's
actually a higher risk
for cancer, marginal zone
lymphomas, and mucosa
-associated lymphoid tissue.
In regards to the diagnosis
of Sjogren's syndrome,
what we'll find is about
in 70% of cases, we have a
positive rheumatoid factor.
However, this is not specific
or sensitive to Sjogren's
syndrome, however a common
finding throughout autoimmune
conditions. Furthermore,
we'll have a positive
ANA, and if we were to do
immunofluorescence, what
we'll actually see is
nuclear speckling, and
that's shown to you in the
third picture on the right
-hand side of the page.
Furthermore, there are
some antibodies that we can
test for, and in this case
specifically, we can look
at anti-rho antibodies,
which stands for anti
-ribonucleoprotein antibodies,
as well as anti-LAW or SSB.
Clinically, we can also
do a Shermer test, which
is really there to just
tell us if there's enough
tears being produced by
the lacrimal glands, and
there's also a predominance
or focus on biopsies.
So if we were to get a
diagnosis, we might do a
lip biopsy, in which case
we'll see lymphoid foci
or perioductal lymphocytic
infiltration into the
salivary glands. And in
some cases, we can do a
parotid gland biopsy as
well. However, this is
typically reserved for
patients who have an atypical
presentation. So you
might see unilateral or
one-sided parotid gland
***********. And that's
more a common finding with
marginal zone lymphoma.
In terms of the treatment,
we're primarily looking
at immunosuppressive
agents such as steroids or
prednisone. And there are
some medications we can use
like pilocarpine. So this
is actually colonomimetic,
and it's for the
treatment of dry eyes or
xerostomia on top of just
the use of artificial tears.
So now we'll stop for a
minute and just try to test
our knowledge with a quick
case. So in this case,
we have a 15-year-old
male presenting to the ER
with tachypnea, and labs
demonstrate an elevated glucose
as well as a high anti
-gap metabolic acidosis.
Furthermore, he has no
past medical history of
his own, but his family
does report high sugars in
several family members
starting at a young age.
What is the underlying
pathological process? So
the answer here is B,
which is cytotoxic T-cell
involvement and
macrophage involvement and
infiltration into the beta
cells of the pancreas.
And in looking at the
question, we're presented
with Kussmaul respirations,
or tachypnea is how
it's described, and labs
demonstrate the acidosis
that you would see in
diabetic ketoacidosis with
the elevated glucose or
elevated blood sugar.
In terms of some of the
other options, letter A is
primarily looking at
the process involved in
Sjogren's syndrome, and
looking at C, this is a non
-specific answer. There's
actually many autoimmune
conditions and disorders
that have IgG responses.
Next, we'll turn our
attention a little bit over to
autoimmune diseases of the
gastrointestinal tract.
We'll talk about a few
specific disease processes,
and essentially what we'll
talk about is also how
they compare against one
another. What you'll find
is in all of your review
materials, test questions,
as well as some of the board
-relevant material, many
of the questions come
from the comparison of one
disease process to another,
such as Crohn's disease
versus ulcerative colitis.
So we'll try to touch on
that a little bit as we
go through our discussion.
First, we'll discuss
primary biliary cholangitis,
and in this case, the exact
mechanism and etiology are
actually unclear, but
we do know that there's
lymphocytic infiltrates, and
granulomatous inflammation.
In this case, we do have
specific antibodies, so
we have antimitychondrial
antibodies. However, similar
to insulin-dependent
diabetes mellitus, the
antibodies don't play a role
in the etiology, however,
are specific findings
for this disease process.
The area that's being
affected is the medium-sized
intrahepatic bile ducts,
and in this case, what we'll
have for our signs and
symptoms, the mechanism is
actually important to
know. What we'll see is the
patients experience symptoms
of bile obstruction. This
is because the bile is
blocked in the same place
that your blood is drained
from the liver and so what
we have is an accumulation
of bile. This ultimately
will lead to jaundice as
well as light colored stool.
You'll have darkened urine
and as well you'll find
pruritus or itching diffusely
throughout the skin.
The mechanism for the
pruritus isn't entirely clear,
but some of the recent
literature does show that
there's lysophosphatidic
acid in the bile itself,
and this is actually a
mediator of the pruritus.
The bile itself is also
made of cholesterol, and
so what happens is because
the bile is unable to
leave the liver, the body
senses this, and so what
we do is we decrease our
conversion of cholesterol
into bile, but this extra
cholesterol needs to go
somewhere. So what you'll
see is patients will
present with xanthomas or
actually cholesterol deposits
on their skin commonly
seen in the Achilles tendon
region or above the
eyelid. And you'll also see
this excreted into the
feces called steatorrhea.
In terms of our diagnosis
of primary biliary
cholangitis, what we'll see
on labs is an obstructive
picture and that'll be
manifested with an elevation
of alkaline phosphatase.
Now alkaline phosphatase
is also seen in not
only liver pathology but
bone pathology so to
discriminate between the two
we'll actually do a further
test called a GGT or
gamma glutamyl transferase
and if both of these
the alkaline phosphatase
and the GGT are elevated
we're dealing specifically
with liver pathology.
Furthermore, we'll have
hypercholesterolemia.
We're talking about the
elevation of your cholesterol
overall because we're
decreasing that synthesis
and conversion from
cholesterol into bile.
Furthermore, there's no
problem with the innate
conjugation of the bile
itself. So what we'll have
is actually the bile will
be conjugated. You'll have
a direct or conjugated
hyperbilirubinemia. In
about 93% of cases, you'll
actually have a positive
antimitochondrial antibody.
However, in about 7% of
those cases, the people that
were missing, we can
actually go forward with the
liver biopsy. And there's
staging that's demonstrated
stage 1 to stage 4, ultimately
leading to cirrhosis.
But what's important
for you to know is that
initially you'll see portal
inflammation, and around
the ducts you'll see
fibrosis. In the areas that
aren't involved in terms
of the biliary ducts and
biliary treat, they'll be
dilated, and what's commonly
described is a beaded
appearance on imaging. The
treatment overall for this
is USDA, or ursodeoxycholic
acid, and what this does
is it breaks down the
cholesterol to facilitate
bile excretion. So this
doesn't actually regress your
disease, but it does slow
down the disease
progression, especially with
slowing down the histological
progression and changes.
Now we'll be discussing
pernicious anemia, and in
this case the mechanism of
action is IgG autoantibodies
against the parietal
cells or intrinsic
factor, and these two
somewhat go hand in hand. So
what we have is the process
with parietal cells also
involves oximptic cells,
and these make the
intrinsic factor. Intrinsic
factor and conjunction with
B12 form a complex and
these actually both together
are transported across
the intestinal mucosa.
When we have production
of these antibodies
against the intrinsic
factor there's prevention
of this uptake and so
what happens is the plasma
cells in your gastric
mucosa actually secrete
this antibody into the
lumen of the stomach.
Again, this is organ
specific. We're specifically
dealing with gastroparietal
cells. However, the signs
and stigmata of this
disease process will be seen
throughout the body. So what
we'll have here is angular
colitis, which looks like
cracked lips in the corner
of your mouth. Commonly,
people will mistake these
for cold sores. Along that
same line you'll also see
glossitis which is tongue
inflammation to the point
where you actually see not
only swelling but a smooth
tongue and there's also
signs and symptoms of
neuropathy due to the b12
losses. So this is commonly
tested and seen because
there's a lot of different
autoimmune conditions like
diabetes where people can
have neuropathy confused for
either vitamin deficiencies
or nerve damage. This
neuropathy ultimately leads
to loss of proprioception
or sensations of feeling.
What we also see is
because this ultimately
leads to an anemia from
the B12 deficiency,
we have pallor, weakness,
as well as fatigue.
In terms of the diagnosis
of pernicious anemia,
we can actually do lab
testing with your blood
or serum for vitamin
B12 amounts, And so what
we'll see is a low amount
or level of vitamin B12.
In terms of the anemia
itself, if you're thinking
of a microcytic, normocytic,
or macrocytic picture,
specifically in reference
to the MCV, or mean
corpuscular volume, what
we'll find is that these
pernicious anemias from B12
will actually be macrocytic.
So the mean corpuscular
volume is over 100.
Now another thing or
another cause of your
macrocytic anemia is
also folate deficiency
as well as B12 deficiency.
So to distinguish
between the two we can
do further testing.
So when we're suspicious
when we have a macrocytic
anemia there's low
vitamin B12 or folic acid
or folate we're not sure
what to do next. We check
for homocysteine as well
as methylmalonic acid
And what we'll find in
the case of pernicious
anemia, specifically from
what we're talking about
here in low vitamin
B12, you have increased
homocysteine and an increase
in methylmalonic acid.
However, if we were
looking at only
folate deficiency,
your methylmalonic
acid levels, or
MMA, will be normal.
Other testing can also
be completed, such
as endoscopy with
biopsy. and I'll talk to
you a little bit about
the Schilling test,
which has somewhat
fallen to the wayside.
In terms of the treatment,
specifically we're looking
at vitamin B12 with
intramuscular injections and
supplementation. Now if you
think about it, there are
vitamin B12 pills,
chocolates, different types of
supplements, but if you're
taking this by mouth and have a
concern or problem with
absorption, regardless of your
consumption and increase
in your supplementation,
you're not going to be
absorbing any of it. So what
we'll do is intramuscular
injection, so this can quickly
access the venous system
and be absorbed and used.
Now the Schilling test
is actually a two-part
test, and what this
does is we take a
radiolabeled B12 and take
a supplement by mouth.
On top of that, we take a
supplement intramuscularly
that's not radiolabeled,
the idea being we want to
absorb as much of the B12
as we can, but we don't
want all that radio-labeled
B12 to be absorbed by our
tissues, so we'll give an
intramuscular supplement.
And we'll check the
levels of the B12 that's
excreted in the urine.
If that first round of
testing is abnormal, we
move to the second round.
Here we do the same thing,
an oral supplement that's
radio-labeled, we also do
the injection, but there's
also the addition of intrinsic
factor. So we'll actually
supplement and give people
intrinsic factor. The problem
becomes this intrinsic
factor has to come from
somewhere and it's typically
used in porcine or bovine
products, so it came from
pigs or cows and so what we'll
find in literature is a few
cases and case reports of
bovine or spongiform bovine
encephalopathy which is
commonly known as mad cow
disease and so you'll see that
this Schilling test has
often fallen to the wayside.
next we'll be talking about
ulcerative colitis and
oftentimes what we see especially
when it comes to testing
is ulcerative colitis as
an entity is often compared
with crohn's disease so
it's good to know the
comparisons between the two
and there are some overlaps
that you'll also see in both
disease processes overall
the mechanism of action
the etiology is actually
unclear, but we do know
that there's submucosal and
mucosal involvement through
a TH2 mediated inflammation.
And what we'll see is in
terms of organ specific, the
most common presentation
or very common presentation
is actually involvement of
the ****** or left-sided
colon. And the easy way to
differentiate, especially
on testing between the
two, is Crohn's versus UC.
Ulcerative colitis typically
has a ****** diarrhea
while Crohn's is described
as a watery diarrhea.
There's also the left
-sided left lower quadrant
pain in ulcerative colitis
because there's involvement
of the distal colon and
there's also in Crohn's
disease versus ulcerative
colitis Crohn's will be
described as skip lesions.
You'll have oral ulcers
all the way down to the
lower part of the colon
and intestines. However
in ulcerative colitis I'm
mentioning that the ******
is typically involved.
In terms of the signs
and symptoms, what you'll
actually find is that
smoking is protective in
ulcerative colitis. I
don't think it's a great
reason to tell your patients
to smoke, but in terms
of presentations, you'll
have ****** diarrhea,
bright red blood
per ******, anemia
can also be seen,
as well as, as I
mentioned, that left
lower quadrant pain.
What you'll also find
is there's inflammation
really in multiple places.
For example, you'll
have inflammation in
the eye, such as uveitis
or episcleritis. There's
also joint inflammation
and joint involvement.
And this is not only
seen as arthritis, but a
lot of the seronegative
spondyloarthropathies.
And there's also
oral ulcers called
apthysstomatitis.
Now there's also a
common rash that's
described, pyoderma
gangrenosum, which really is
tissue necrosis leading
to quite deep ulcers,
and it's typically
present in the legs.
And you can also develop
primary sclerosing cholangitis,
not the disease that we
had talked about earlier,
primary biliary cholangitis,
but both of these
disease processes are associated
actually with P. ANCA,
which we'll be discussing
briefly on our next slide.
In regards to the diagnosis
of ulcerative colitis,
what we'll have is an increase
in the ESR or erythrocyte
sedimentation rate kind
of pointing to a sign of
inflammation as well as a
decreased hemoglobin and
hematocrit pointing to that
anemia picture which we briefly
mentioned below. What
we'll also find is positive
P-ANCA which is perinuclear
antineutrophilic cytoplasmic
antibodies and these are
targeted specifically
against myeloperoxidase,
which is found in neutrophils.
So pianka is not specific
to just ulcerative
colitis, but it's
also seen in other
microscopic polyangitis
type diseases,
Churk-Strauss syndrome.
You'll hear about it with
primary sclerosing
cholangitis, as we mentioned on
the slide prior. In terms
of other testing, it's
important to send stool
bacterial cultures in order to
rule out other causes of
****** diarrhea that mimic
signs and symptoms of
ulcerative colitis, such as
salmonella, shigella, we
talk about E. coli as well.
In terms of further testing,
if we were to do a barium
*****, there's actually a
picture that's shown here.
What we'll find is when we
do a double contrast barium
*****, it leads to what's
called a lead pipe sign,
and this is because there's
actually a loss of hostra,
making the colon look smooth,
walled and cylindrical.
Furthermore, you can
do endoscopic biopsy
to also demonstrate
the findings of
ulcerative colitis as
well as colonoscopy.
In terms of just the
gross morphology, what
you'll find, and this
is a common distinction
between ulcerative
colitis and Crohn's
disease, is that you'll
have with ulcerative
colitis mucosal and
submucosal inflammation.
The mucosa is also friable
and there's variable
depth of ulcerations.
However, with
ulcerative colitis, this
is not transmural. It is
not going through the
intestine completely.
There's also
pseudopolyp formation.
Because this is not
transmural, we also don't see
fistula formation in
most cases of ulcerative
colitis. And on microscopy,
ulcerative colitis is
typically described as
having crypt abscesses and
ulcers. However, there is
no granuloma formation.
When looking at the treatment
of ulcerative colitis,
we have 5-ASA or aminosalicylic
acid preparations as
well as things like
sulfasalazine or mechanisms and
medications such as
sulfasalazine. And what that is is
really it's actually a combination
of the 5-aminosalicylic
acid as well as sulfapyridine.
So this is not only
an NSAID type mechanism,
but also an antibacterial.
And so what happens is a
lot of these medications
are NSAIDs or non
-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs that are specifically
metabolized in the
colon. And so these are
useful in these disease
processes as they
primarily affect the colon.
There's also medications
that you'll hear about,
like 6-mercaptopurine,
and this is a purine
antimetabolite. So this
inhibits the synthesis of DNA
and RNA, and in this case,
it actually prohibits
and inhibits the synthesis
of the cells that cause
the inflammatory process
in ulcerative colitis.
There's also some antibody
-type medication, such as
infliximab, and that's
also used to treat the
spondyloarthropathies associated
with ulcerative colitis,
and its mechanism is a
tumor necrosis factor alpha
inhibitor. In very severe
disease, I've seen this before
as well, you'll see colectomies
performed on patients,
especially in those who
have diseases that are
refractory to any of the
treatments available. If
there's signs and stigmata
of dysplasia or cancer and
carcinoma, we'll often see
colectomy being performed.
Now that we've discussed
many of the diseases of the
gastrointestinal tract and
gastrointestinal system,
we'll take a second here
to rehearse and practice
with the case. So here we
have a 22-year-old female
presenting to the clinic
with a chief complaint of
****** diarrhea and what she
describes to be cold sores
at the corners of her
lips that have not healed.
She does report recent
camping trip but denies any
fevers or chills? Her labs
are demonstrated below.
What is the potential
disease process at hand?
So take a second to think
about what's going on here.
Now there's enough in the
stem of the question to lead
you to the answer that we've
discussed already. However,
think about it a little
bit more broadly and make
sure you're considering all
senses of the differential.
If there's vascular causes,
inflammatory causes, is
it drug-induced, idiopathic,
in this case, what are
the autoimmune considerations,
or endocrine, metabolic.
So what we're looking at
in terms of our patient
here, this recent camping
trip might point you to
some of the bacterial
causes, but with that what
we might see is the
leukocyte count or WBC count
that's elevated pointing
to an infection. However,
that's within normal
limits. We had mentioned
before with ulcerative
colitis, you might see
an anemia, which you see
here with the patient's
reduced hemoglobin as well
as reduced hematocrit.
Furthermore,
not only do we have
the P. Anka findings,
but there's also the
elevation of the ESR
pointing to an inflammatory
type condition.
So while the answer
here was ulcerative
colitis, it's
important to make sure
you're considering a
broad differential,
especially when you're
presented with a substantial
amount of information and
lab findings and clinical
findings that may point
to more than one thing.
Next, we'll turn
our attention over
to autoimmune diseases
of the kidney.
And what you'll find is
there's actually a whole
host of nephrotic and
nephritic syndromes and kidney
pathologies that you'll
have to study and ultimately
know for the boards and
for clinical practice. But
what we'll do here is
go over a few key select
conditions that you'll see
in widespread populations and
briefly discuss not only
the mechanisms but how
they might present as well
as some of the treatment
options available. There's
many of these processes
that are not only found in
children but also in adults
and some of the mechanisms
make them particularly
unique in comparison to
the other kidney diseases.
The first disease process
that we'll be talking
about is post-streptococcal
glomerulonephritis,
and in this case, the
mechanism at play is IgG,
IgM, and C3-mediated with
complex and deposition on
glomerular basement membranes
and mesangium. In this
case, it's a very specific
type of pathogenesis called
molecular mimicry, and
in this case, we're also
dealing with group A strep
or strep pharyngitis also
causing impetigo, leading to
be the nephrodogenic agent.
Specifically, the M protein
is actually what's known
as the virulence factor
in this disease process.
What we'll see is that
it's also organ specific,
specifically with the renal
glomerular basement membrane
and the mesangium.
However, just like all the
other processes, there are
systemic signs and stigmata.
So what we'll see oftentimes
in children is that
the process is actually
asymptomatic. However, it
does go upwards to leading
to a nephrotic syndrome.
Commonly, it's seen in
children, typically about
two to four weeks after a
group A strep infection.
However, it can progress
to renal disease in adults.
Some of the other findings
that you might see is
periorbital and peripheral
edema, that's in line
with the nephrotic
syndrome. And because the
kidneys are affected, this
can also be a secondary
cause of hypertension
or high blood pressure.
In terms of the diagnosis
of post-treptococcal
glomerulonephritis, keep in
mind the disease process uses
IgM, IgG, and C3, and we're
using these to form complex
deposition on your glomerular
basement membrane. So
if we're testing for C3,
it's being used up on these
depositions, and so you'll
actually have low levels
of C3. On top of that, we
can test for ASO titers or
antistreptolysin O
titers, which can also
help to confirm the
diagnosis of PSGN.
If you were to proceed
with immunofluorescence
microscopy, what you
might find or common
descriptions are a starry
night appearance or a
lumpy bumpy appearance,
and this is because of
that granular deposition
of the antigen-antibody
complex in the glomerular
basement membrane.
On top of this, with
electron microscopy,
you might also see
findings of sub-epithelial
immune complex
depositions consistent
with what we had seen
and discussed before.
In terms of our treatments,
we're talking about
antihypertensives because we
were mentioning previously
that one of the signs of
this disease process is
hypertension, as well as
antibiotics, because keep
in mind this is caused
by a group A strep infection.
And for the nephrotic
syndrome sequelae, we
can talk about sodium
restriction and diuretics
and predominantly supportive
care. Now, I want to make
one point clear is that
in terms of antibiotics,
this does not prevent
the progression of group
A strep to PSGN. However,
the administration of
antibiotics like penicillin
G can prevent the nephrodogenic
strain from spreading
from one person to
another. So it's not
necessarily to halt the
progression from group A strep
to this kidney malfunction.
However, it can help in
stopping the spread from
one person to the next.
Next, we'll be discussing
Goodpasture syndrome. And in
this case, the mechanism
of action is IgG-mediated
autoantibodies against the
intrinsic antigen of the
glomerulobasement membrane.
So there are some genetic
associations in this case,
specifically with HLA-DR2. However,
commonly described is a
finding of an upper respiratory
infection prior to the
presentation of Goodpasture
syndrome or the presentations
of pulmonary hemorrhage
leading to hemoptysis or a
cough with blood, rapidly
progressive glomerulonephritis,
which will present with
hematuria or blood in the
urine. Typically, this is
described in adults, and this
is a type 3 hypersensitivity
reaction because of the
interaction of the IgM and
IgG, as well as complex
formation with your antigen.
In regards to the diagnosis
of Goodpasture syndrome,
what we'll find in over
90% of cases is actually
anti-GBM antibodies and
also looking for findings
in other areas. As we
mentioned hematuria and
hemoptysis, you'll also see
chest x-ray findings consistent
with pulmonary infiltrates.
And if you were to
proceed with immunofluorescence
microscopy, you'll
find a linear pattern because
this follows the pattern
of the membranes such as
the alveolar membrane.
In terms of the treatment,
The three treatment
modalities mentioned are
corticosteroids, which
is consistent with many
of the autoimmune processes
we've discussed, as
well as cyclophosphamide
and plasmapheresis.
Lastly, we're finally in
the home stretch. We'll
briefly discuss a few of the
autoimmune diseases of the
skin, and there are a few
key words and pictures that
you'll see commonly presented
in many of the situations
you'll come across, whether
it be on the boards,
your comats, or in clinical
practice, and we'll try
to highlight those as we
go through the discussion.
The first disease process that
we'll mention is pemphigus
vulgaris, in which case
the mechanism of action
is IgG autoantibodies against
desmoglion 1 and or the
inclusion and involvement
of desmoglion 3. And these
proteins or desmosomes, what
they're in charge of doing
and maintain is the connection
between keratinocytes
in reference to the stratum
spinosum layer. And so
what we'll have is there's
mucosal and possibly the
involvement of the cutaneous
epithelial cell junctions.
Specifically, Desmoglion
3 alone is more
associated with mucosal
disease, while the
presence of Desmoglion
1 and 3 involvement is
more of a mucocutaneous
disease presentation.
In terms of the signs
and symptoms, commonly,
commonly described is a
positive Nikolsky sign. In this
case, with a positive
Nikolsky sign, when the
bullae that are formed,
these mucocutaneous or
cutaneous eruptions are
formed, these bullae, the top
layers of the skin, when
they're slightly touched,
they slough or they slip
apart from the lower
layers. This actually
differentiates the disease from
a different disease
process called bullous
pemphigoid. In that case,
when you actually touch the
bullae, they're firm and
are not able to separate.
So very important to
know the difference
between the two with the
positive Nikolsky sign.
In terms of diagnosis of
pemphigus vulgaris, there's
a few different modalities
that we can use. Keep in
mind, the entire mechanism
of all of these are the
idea that there's deposition
of the anti-desmoglian
antibodies, specifically
against Desmoglian 1 and
Desmoglian 3. So if we were
to do light microscopy, the
process that you might see
is called acantholysis.
Sometimes this will be
described differently, such
as in a row of tombstones.
And the reason this
happens is because, keep
in mind, when you're
sloughing off the skin,
it's really just the top
layer that's coming off
that you're pulling off.
And so the basement
membrane is still intact. So
when you pull off this
top layer from the bottom,
what appears to be shown
is a tombstone pattern.
On top of that you can
also do what's called
immunofluorescence leading to
a reticular pattern. Sometimes
people will call this a lacy
pattern and occasionally
I've seen it called a fishnet
pattern as well. So there's
definitely a few different
ways that this can be
described. In terms of the
treatment primarily we'll
use corticosteroids but
the other mechanism and the
other treatment that you'll
see is rituximab. So this is
actually a chemotherapeutic
or anti-tumor medication,
and it's chimeric, meaning
it still has some animal
protein fragments. It's a
monoclonal antibody that
selectively targets CD20,
which is found on B-cells. And
so you'll activate a complement
-dependent cytotoxicity
on these B-cells to lead
to apoptosis. So those are
the treatments and diagnosis
for pemphigus vulgaris.
And lastly, we'll
turn our attention to
autoimmune diseases of
the vascular system.
The first disease we'll mention
is immune thrombocytopenic
purpura, in which case
you have autoantibodies
against GP2B and 3A, and
these are both receptors in
platelet aggregation, and
they stop the platelet plug
essentially from forming.
And what we'll find is
dysfunction in your blood and
platelets. So with the signs
and symptoms, will have
purpura and mucocutaneous
bleeding specifically because
of the platelet dysfunction
and on top of that ultimately
you can have splenic
destruction. Initially
you might see splenomegaly
because the macrophages help
to phagocytose the platelets
that are dysfunctional
leading to the splenomegaly
and ultimately splenic
destruction and signs and symptoms
and presentation are
commonly pallor and fatigue.
In terms of diagnosis of
immune thrombocytopenic purpura
we have specifically an
isolated thrombocytopenia
or low platelet count and
it's predominantly a diagnosis
of exclusion so much of
the testing that will be
done is actually excluding
other diseases. For example
you might do a blood smear
and see findings like
schistocytes and that'll point
you more in the direction
of TTP or hemolytic uremic
syndrome and other disease
processes. In terms of the
treatment, it does somewhat
vary based off of the
population of children or
adults, and in children
it's really supportive care
predominantly, but when we
get to adults, we do have
corticosteroids, IVIG, and again
we're mentioning rituximab.
In this case, rituximab
targets the B cells that
are responsible for
producing the antibodies that
destroy your platelets. So
rituxanab binds to the B cells
to help your immune
system destroy the B cell,
decreasing the overall burden
of the antibody production.
And lastly, we'll be
discussing antiphospholipid
syndrome. This might not be
a disease process that you
commonly see. However, when
you're considering patients
with recurrent thrombotic
events like spontaneous
abortions, deep vein
thrombosis, pulmonary emboli,
this does become a big
differential to consider in
your patients who have
hypercoagulable conditions and
hypercoagulable states.
So here it's an autoimmune
disease specifically with
autoantibodies or antibodies
to cardiolipin and lupus
anticoagulant and these
react against the proteins
that bind to the plasma
membrane. So this can be
primary or secondary meaning on
its own antiphospholipid
syndrome is a primary syndrome.
However, you can also
find this in conjunction
or along with lupus. Now,
it's not organ-specific. It
is a hematologic consideration,
but can go across
multiple body systems and
organ systems. There's a
classification system on the
next slide that will tell
you that really in more
than three body systems or
organ systems involved, this
can become catastrophic.
I mentioned again, these
patients will have recurrent
thrombotic events,
deep pain thrombosis,
spontaneous abortions, CVAs,
or myocardial infarctions.
And furthermore, another
finding on skin exam
you'll see, which is not
specific to this disease
process, is levito
reticularis, which appears
as mottled or lacy
reticular appearing skin.
Now this process does
actually have its own
classification criteria,
but what's important for
you to know is we need
the positive findings
of anticardiolipin,
IgG, or IgM, as well as
positive lupus anticoagulant,
and you may also have
findings positive for
beta-2 glycoprotein 1.
On top of the lab
findings, you also have
clinical findings of
vascular thromboses,
pregnancy morbidities, and the
recurrent thrombotic events.
Because this is a hypercoagulable
state, the treatment
is lifelong anticoagulation
with warfarin. Typically
heparin is actually used
in pregnant patients.
Now that we've discussed
antiphospholipid syndrome
that does bring us to the
end of our lecture and end
of our discussion. One thing
that I like to do and one
thing that I think may
help in understanding the
lecture and the content that
we had just discussed is
coming up with a small chart
to consider the differences
in each disease process.
The things that can
become complicated are when
clinical presentation are
often the same, but I
think making a chart of the
different antibodies, the
clinical signs that might
overlap or might distinguish
one from another, and also
some of the histological
or pathological findings
that you'd see are what's
going to be able to help you
in distinguishing one
disease process from another.
That being said, we are at the
end of our lecture
and discussion.
Thank you to everyone who
tuned in and took notes on
this discussion and this
lecture. Thanks again to Dr.
Slaman for the opportunity
and help with the content.
I have added the SurveyMonkey
link for lecture feedback,
so please, please, please,
if there are things
that you absolutely did not
like, make sure I find out
about it. If there's things
you did enjoy, let me know
so I can incorporate that
into my future lectures.
I have added my email
address below, so if
you have any feedback
for me directly, or if
you have questions
about the content, would
like clarifications,
or more information,
please do not hesitate
to email me. Thank you.